Problem 31.
Use the problem below
to answer the
question that follows.
All right, so this
is our problem.
A red car and a blue car compete
in two 100 mile races.
That's the first race, that's
the second race.
In the first race, both cars
leave the starting
line at the same time.
That's right there.
When the red car crosses the
finish line, the blue car has
10 miles left to go.
They drew that right there.
Red car crosses the finish line,
blue car has 10 miles
left to go.
In the second race, both cars
start at the same time.
But while the blue car begins
at the starting line, right
there, the red car begins
10 miles behind
the starting line.
Fair enough.
Assuming that each car's
average speed does not
change-- that's a
big assumption.
So I'm assuming from race to
race, they have the same
average speed.
How far has the blue car
traveled in the second race
when the red car reaches
the finish line?
So the red car reaches the
finish line, the blue car has
traveled this distance x.
That's what they want us
to solve for, for x.
How far has the blue car
traveled with the red car
finishes the finish line?
Now, this statement right here,
assuming that each car's
average speed, at least in
my brain, is a big clue.
It tells us that that's
important-- that their average
speed is the same.
So from race to race, they don't
have, obviously, the
same average speed.
The red car is faster
in either case.
So let's say that r is equal
to the red's speed.
And let's say that blue is
equal to blue's speed.
Now, in either situation, either
drawing, let's say in
the first race, they
both traveled the
same amount of time.
The same amount of time it took
the red car to go the
whole 100 miles, the blue car
traveled this distance, which
is 90 miles.
How did I know 90 miles?
Because he has 10 miles left
to go in a 100 mile race.
So if we know that distance is
equal to-- sometimes you say
speed times time, or rate times
time; I'll use speed,
just because I already
used r-- is equal
to speed times time.
That also tells us that
time is equal to
distance divided by speed.
So in the first race, in race
1, the time that the red car
took to finish the 100 miles
is 100 miles divided by r
miles per hour.
And notice, the units will
cancel out properly.
If you divide miles by miles
per hour, you're left just
with hours.
So this is the time it takes
for the first car
to finish the race.
Now, we also know that's the
same amount of time it took
the blue car to go 90 miles.
So that is going to be equal to
90 miles over b, or blue's
miles per hour.
Right?
That's what the first
race tells us.
Now, what does the second
race tell us?
The second race, we can
do the same logic.
Race 2.
So, in the time it takes the red
car to travel 110 miles.
Right?
He drives the whole 100 miles,
and he started 10 miles back.
So the red car, 110 miles
divided by red miles per hour
is equal to what?
It's equal to x.
The distance the blue car
travels is equal to x miles
divided by blue's miles
per hour, b miles per
hour, just like that.
Now, what do we have here?
We want to solve for x, and
maybe, just maybe, if we can
find an expression for the ratio
between r and b, then
maybe we can solve for x.
Let me show you what
I mean by that.
Let me switch colors to make
this a little bit less
monotonous.
So this first, from race 1, we
got the information that 100
over r is equal to 90 over b.
If we cross multiply, we
essentially get 100b, 100
times b is equal
to 90 times r.
If we divide both sides by
90, we get 100 over 90
b is equal to r.
If you divide both sides by b,
and you swap the sides, you
get r over b is equal
to 100 over 90.
So we know what the ratio of
red speed to blue speed is.
It's 100 to 90.
Now, can we do the
same thing here?
Let me do this in red.
OK, so here, if we cross
multiply, from race 2, we have
110 over r is equal
to x over b.
If we cross multiply, we get
110b is equal to rx.
And then, let's see, if we
divide both sides by x, we get
110 over x b is equal to r.
And then if we divide both sides
by b, we get 110 over x
is equal to r over b.
That's the information that
the second race gave us.
Now, the first race already
told us what r
over b is equal to.
It's equal to 100 over 90.
So we can replace r over b,
based on the information in
the first race, with
100 over 90.
Now, let's see, so our big
takeaway-- notice, they don't
want us to solve for x, they
just want us to set up the
problem-- is 110 over x is
equal to 100 over 90.
Now, let's see which of these
choices say that.
110 over x is equal
to 100 over 90.
That's choice A.
Just like that.
Next problem.
All right.
Use the diagram below
to answer the
question that follows.
The diagram above is used to
describe the relationship
between the circumference--
right, the circumference is
going around the circle-- the
radius-- that's the radius--
and the area of a circle.
The area, we know what
the area is.
Assuming that the circle is
divided into enough sections
so that the figure on the
right approximates a
rectangle, which of the
following relationships is
demonstrated?
So here they divided
into six wedges.
It looks like a Trivial Pursuit
piece, and they put
them all up.
But you could imagine, if you
made the wedges even thinner,
if you divided into 12 wedges,
then it would start
to look like this.
It would look like this if you
did it into 12 wedges.
And if you did it into 24
wedges, it would start looking
more and more like a rectangle
that looks
something like that.
The more you divide the
wedges, it looks more
and more like that.
So let's see what they're
trying to show us.
So if this is r, right here.
On the wedges, this distance--
or actually this
distance-- is also r.
Right?
That distance is also r.
The whole thing is obviously
the circumference.
Over here, on our kind of
approximated rectangle, what's
our circumference?
Well, our circumference is that
plus that, plus that,
plus that.
So if we just look at maybe
the base of our rectangle,
that is 1/2 our circumference.
Right?
That's 1/2 our circumference.
Because our circumference is
these arcs plus this arc,
these three arcs.
This is just 1/2 of them.
So the area of the rectangle,
the area of this rectangle--
which is the same thing as the
area of the circle, because
all we did is we just kind
of cut up the circle and
rearranged it into a rectangle,
a reapproximated
rectangle-- the area of the
circle of the rectangle is
going to be the base, which
is equal to 1/2 times the
circumference, times the height,
which is the radius.
And, well, lucky for me, that's
actually the actual
choice, choice A.
Just like that.
Actually, this is
a fun exercise.
Maybe I'll do a whole video
explaining why area is 1/2 the
radius times the circumference
using this example.
Because if you divide it into
more and more and more wedges,
it's going to look more and
more like a rectangle.
I'll leave that for you
to experiment with.
Problem 33.
A pretzel company sells pretzels
in a cylindrical
container with a radius
of 10 centimeters
and a height of 30.
Let me draw it.
So a cylindrical container,
radius is 10 centimeters, and
then the height of our container
is 30 centimeters.
Right?
It's all centimeters.
The company's packaging
designers are considering
switching to a new cylindrical
container with a radius of
20-- so it's a bigger radius,
radius of 20 centimeters-- and
a height of 15 centimeters.
How does the volume of the
proposed new container compare
to the volume of the
old container?
So the old container's volume is
going to be this area times
the height.
So it's going to be, so
the volume is equal to
the area pi r squared.
r is 10.
r squared is 100.
So it's going to be 100pi,
that's the area up here.
That's 100pi.
And then we're going to multiply
that times the
height, times 30 centimeters,
and so it's going to be equal
to 3,000pi cubic centimeters.
That's our old container.
Our new container-- what's
the area up here?
Pi r squared.
The area is equal to
pi times r squared.
r is 20.
20 squared is 400.
So our volume is equal
to 400pi times 15.
And what's 400 times 15?
400 times 15 is what?
6,000.
400 times 10 is 4,000.
400 times 5 is 2,000.
Right.
It's 6,000.
So the volume of our new
container is 6,000pi
centimeters, or cubic
centimeters.
So our new container
has twice the
volume of our old container.
So let's see if they say that.
Let's see.
The volume of the new container
is twice the volume
of the old container.
That is correct.
Choice D.
Next problem.
All right.
A fuel tank was approximately
1/8 full.
After adding $50 worth of fuel,
the tank was 3/4 full.
If the fuel cost p dollars
per gallon, all right,
approximately how many gallons
does the tank hold when full?
So, let's see, we added $50, and
it's p dollars per gallon,
so we added-- so 50 divided by
p gallons took us from 1/8 to
3/4 full of a tank.
So how much did it add?
We went from 3/4 of a tank--
from 1/8 of a tank to 3/4.
So how much did we add?
If we just take the difference
between the two, we can
rewrite 3/4 as 6/8, minus
1/8, equal to 5/8.
So we added 5/8 of a tank.
Going from 1/8 to 3/4 is
adding 5/8 of a tank.
So this is equal to 5/8 of
a tank, of a tank of
gas, of our fuel tank.
Now they're saying,
approximately how many gallons
does the tank hold when full?
And it's all in terms of p.
So to solve for one tank, we
can multiply both sides of
this equation times the
reciprocal of this, times 8/5.
Let's do that.
So you multiply 8 over 5 on the
left-hand side, times 8
over 5 on the right-hand side.
And then you're left with--
well, that can just cancel.
5's cancel here.
8's cancel here.
That's why I did it.
So one tank is equal to 8 over
5, times 50 over p gallons.
So if we just divide the
numerator and the denominator
by 5, it becomes 10.
That becomes 1.
8 times 10 is 80 over p gallons,
is equal to 1 tank.
And that is choice A.
Next question.
A homeowner-- let me switch
colors-- a homeowner is
planning to use carpet tiles to
cover the floor of a room
measuring 9 feet by
10 feet, 8 inches.
So it's 9 feet by 10
feet, 8 inches.
Whenever I see that, I like to
write it as a decimal, or I
like to write it just
purely as inches.
How many inches is this?
10 feet is 120 inches, right?
12 inches per foot.
So 120 plus 8.
So this is also 128 inches.
So I'll just write that there.
So it's 9 feet by 128 inches.
If the carpet tiles are 8 inches
wide and 1 foot long,
and there are no gaps between
the tiles when they're placed
on the floor, how many carpet
tiles will the homeowner need
to cover the floor
of the room?
So I'm going to place them this
way, just because I kept
this side in foot.
So I'm going to use the foot
dimension on the foot side.
So this is 1 foot by 8 inches.
Right?
That's the dimension
of our tile.
Let me do it in a
different color.
It's 1 foot on this side
right here, and
then 8 inches on that.
So clearly, we're going to be
able to add-- we're going to
have 9 tiles, because
we have 9 feet.
So we're going to have 9 tiles
in this direction.
And then how many tiles
in this direction?
It's 8 inches, and we have
a total of 128 inches.
So how many times does
8 to go into 128?
8 goes into 12 once,
1 times 8 is 8, 48.
8 goes into 48 six times.
So you'll have 16 tiles
in that direction.
9 tiles here in the, I guess,
on the width, 16
tiles in the length.
So we're going to have
16 times 9 tiles.
6 times 9 is 54.
1 times 9 is 9, plus 5 is 14.
So we're going to
need 144 tiles.
So that's choice C.